noi siamo calati su joi esserlo e ho
detto è tra l'altro tra imbatte royale
vari che ci sono io ho visto cioè la
regione sta uno però poi vi fece anche
di stand sabato c'è praticamente tu puoi
giocare siamo già partiti incredibile
mattino marco ha spiegato che prendete
tu puoi giocare e vinci in base alla
distanza in cui zac i buchini puoi anche
azzeccare il paese ma non solo puoi
anche azzeccare bene il punto dove sei e
vinci in base a chi ci azzecca prima
cioè in base a chi sta più o meno dove
adesso come questa e sud america per far
tenere dentro poi magari non è sud
america
io metto tipo qua e non so bene se
effettivamente azzeccato meno magari
svela però gli altri hanno sbagliato più
di me quindi chi se ne frega no lui ti
dice dove sei vicino a io avevo
azzeccato a 300 ok ok ed era giusto
comunque era più o meno acqua e gas plus
anno 2.600 chilometri però non è male
sono stato uno dei migliori ho fatto
usato un tentativo solo non è male sta
modalità ragazzi è un po diversa non è
male qua siamo sempre sud america e ad
magari c'è scritto qui dietro c'è
scritto e detto il coso dell'immondizia
fermi evergreen che potrebbe essere
qualsiasi cosa che amo sudamerica
innanzitutto sempre tipo brasile ok no
16mila chilometri non azzecca do niente
a 3mila chilometri ho sbagliato tutto
stavolta diamo era qui e li realizzava
mentre qua non male ma ho capito come è
un po più complicato dell'altro
però si può fare cioè non è che non si
può fare gli altri hanno azzeccato quasi
tutti c'è chi abbandona ci ha preso in
pieno
va bene o quanto è facile messa che so
se questa poi è facile ragazze russe sta
qua in tunisia tipo qua ho messo lì più
o meno ma non è non è proprio lì ma più
o meno più sopra tipo qui non era male
rispetto agli altri alcuno lazio che era
sbagliata completamente gli altri
avevano a zero cioè al cartello
questa potrebbe essere l'italia non è
vero
vedo dei cartelli quale con subito
questi centar est europa l'europa est
europa l'europa dell'est ma non so bene
dove potrebbe essere polacchi a potrebbe
essere ovunque ha detto quantico tra
polonia e la slovacchia la polacca più o
meno acqua e comunque sono quello che ha
azzeccato di meno peccato e molto bene
molto difficile stanno dall'italia se
posso dire molto critici dall'altra però
però non è male non è male andiamo sul
country battle che il più classico di
tutti questa ragazzina parecchio
difficile soprattutto per il fatto che
non si capisce un cacchio quindi come si
gioca a meno che non hai giocato già 26
volte ok ragazzi cos'è in mezzo all
milano milano milan o il bobbio capire
se siamo almeno in america 1 beh beh non
siamo in america allora and giuristi
dealing streelman non ho idea di dove
minchia possa essere non una minima idea
che hanno azzeccato l'inter abbia un
personaggio c'è un cartello col ne so
meno di prima
credo sia tipo di tipo qua da islam che
culo o l'hanno provata che si perchè
vedevo stecca r che erano troppe erano
troppo erano troppo da da islanda troppo
è molto lontana l'islanda è vicino a
padova
l'ho vista madonna che cosa pazzesca
queste nove fermi voglio vivere qua
voglio vivere qui che case incredibile
dove siamo
no ragazzi non ho parole mai dove
dovessero posto incredibile e mi chiamò
a casa una casa brutta c'è il suo posto
in condominio
non so madonna lega a pazzesca sta roba
guarda che cose pazzesche ma dove siamo
ma fermi non ho idee non ne ho idea
regalo ciao clifton vero singapore o
regno unito australia
no singapore in capo no era singapore ho
messo il cuore
ho messo va a cagare ma l'ho messo mi ha
fatto perdere
ovvero dai l'omesso porco demonio ma
perché viva il gioco già è difficile suo
gioco ci manca solo che quando ne
singapore porca vacca ho messo giusto ci
ho messo di più avevo messo noi che
siamo qua a zuckerberg non è germania
questa non e germania questo caffè
austria
beh certo se non è zuppa è pan bagnato
quindi è pan bagnato
ecco la tua potrebbe essere il nono
nell'italia qua siamo in est europa
subito subito est europa sposto europa
sicuro est europa molto più probabile le
staccionate non ho mai visto staccionate
nuti in italia ogni niente c'è un
cartello con scritto zorn figlio di
khmer che l'utilizzo di star
cecoslovacchia che non so dove sia
vecchia era il secchia bene molto facile
bella la vecchia ci sono stata una volta
toga amata macchina quindi ho azzeccato
la vecchia vediamo se possiamo andare
avanti con singapore lo vedo subito dal
verde degli alberi verde questo il verde
di singh ha forma donna che bel posto
questo e singapore ragazzi scommetto col
no non è vero e zhang e il 2008 18 che
materia che una decina e in indonesia
regala può essere indonesia and honey
già c'è questo al anche fortissimo
ragazzi perché gli azzeccato comunque
bellissima per indole
programmato ma che chievo
porca vacca siamo agli sgoccioli raga
proprio sicuro non mollano non mollano
chacin che giocava a tennis e una volta
è bravo a giocare
va bene vediamo seccare un cartello per
sbaglio in questi 26 mila chilometri di
strada inutile cavalca c'è un cittadino
qua e là si scola cercare qualcosa non
centrata la macchina non è però una
donna può essere robusto essere ovunque
bielorussia russia mi chiedevi che non
azzeccano gli altri migranti che non gli
altri alan ha sbagliato non never porco
demonio e io che ci hanno andato dritto
ma nayan azzeccati in quattro era
arrivato primo ero stato bravissimo
perché avevo fatto due chilometri
d'autostrada inutile qua invece berkoff
lo zurich zurigo
ma scusa giuria e la svizzera spizzava
molti beni e ce l'abbiamo mesi fatta
ragazzi siamo in tre ovviamente il
tedesco si parla anche l'acqua non è
svizzera sicuro io tedesco a trovare un
posto decente che mi faccia capire dove
siamo
magari tiro avanti di un sacco qua
facciamo finta non ci sono indicazioni
[Musica]
che bandi dai ragazzi a parte quella
dell'italia non lo so chi è che ci ha
rubato la bandiera raul de rivero e
brasile non è brasi però è già in
sudamerica
ecco qua comunque messico la barriera
del messico guerra ad un pirla
era veramente facile qua siamo in africa
ma sto andando dritto per due ore non
trovo niente se non è anche questa qua
non accettiamo né uno né l'altro
cos'è che ha ammesso non so neanche cosa
sia quella bandiera non c'è niente per
un'ora cosa stai sperando litro non c'è
niente se trovo un cartello e file ma
non lo trovo adesso proverà di nuovo a
la senegal azzeccato bravissimo io non
ho trovato nulla per noi sono da tanti
da quando siamo sfondati ragazzi basta
perché oggi mi sono veramente spremuto
c'è stata la battaglia a lui
primo sangue quella di prima e kato che
non l'ho vinta cacchio però che vi sia
piaciuto è stato molto divertente perché
altro che non sono riuscito a vincere la
fame la verità vocazione concetto agazzi
vedo che c'e una volta mi piace anche
perché questa descrizione
dovete chiedere a noi come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]